bello a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo video sono che cosa sta
succedendo
io sono qua dj e questo il secondo
episodio con disney finiti che lei
sarebbe la serie in collaborazione con
disney
l'ultima volta ragazzi avevo fatto il
star wars il mondo di star wars per il
secondo episodio dovrei provare a fare i
side out solo che non a quella frase c'è
tra una mazza che il che il tranquillo
comunque ragazzi c'è ancora la mia
piattaforma l'incredibile che sarebbe
quella vede telecomando quando serve
dove lo sento una mazza non sento la
scena e quelle palle di pelo e allora se
c'è una persona già oggi sia un ragazzo
ha creato ora possiedi perso vero soma
prison questo cosa è successo a lanciare
le meteore che saprà fare l'abbia ce
l'avrà un superpotere quest'uomo mazza
che è utile non essere seriamente sembra
perfetto non ho sembravano ma credetemi
sono tempismo che fa veramente spavento
dai macro avane vero o meno
calmiamoci un attimo perché non ci
stiamo capendo e vabbè allora è va bene
anche se mi ci impegniamo ne prendemmo
quattro prove ponte o di ro ferry
sono ancora vivo ha comunque ragazzi a
pettine essere morto 200 volte che se
quella roba lì a un manuale solamente
sono i palloncini nella scatola bond
ashley esci palloni 5 liquori attiva
bene che non è un due di picche
i ragazzi mi dovete spiegare perché
siamo passati da questo c'è da star wars
da questo tipo un livello ancora il 5 di
cuore esistono anche altre carte rosa
izzy ovvero allora va beh se impiantata
una carta sarà mica 5 di cuori con mio
zio che sono un mago ragazzi sono
indovinare le carte 6 star o mio dio
da piccolo avevo uno uguale identica per
ragazzi il mio sogno più grande sia
avverato ciò era soltanto uno loreo
gigante esattamente come posso averlo
anche nella vita reale questa cosa qua
potessi tornare dentro i video che il
tipo che in terapia altro che che intera
piacevo olio reo dentro ai videogame ho
avuto io siamo attaccati dai 5 di cuori
ragazzi ci stanno attaccando i 5 di
cuori sono la feccia la feccia è un
ricordo speciale questo è un ma va a
cagare anno mi serviva anche allora
niente consente la mira tu oggi la stai
avendo cioè che dice vuoi fare zio
perfetto bravo che cestista complimenti
dei sandali dell'eiff le infradito
novabell seriamente i ragazzi odio le se
volete farmi un regalo regalatemi delle
infradito perché veramente lanciano alla
finestra una presa elettrica anche in
america avevo trovato nelle prese della
corrente così tristi uguali le prese
della corrente in america sono sono
troppo tristi
la soluzione è la cipolla gol
cosa c'entra 5 di qualsiasi cosa ragazzi
facciate in matematica la risposta sarà
5 liguori basta ho capito adesso mi
aiutano
adesso il 5 di quelli sono la soluzione
fantastico no no non ci credo
da vai a fare un salto uno in sala sai
rischiando grosso zio tonico perfetto lo
dite voi cosa ci devo fare con questa
cosa perché io un'idea ce l'avrei
perfetto ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta di
importarli importante che ho consegnato
la palla ma che sesto raggio a si
schianta c'è utile una cosa non doveva
fare quella fatta per fantasy vicolo
cieco
ho finito perfetto nuovo assetto
sbloccato una fatta
ci siamo oh mio dio 9 in 2 dic fiducia
la mia guarda anche agile guardala
unicorni mia finire a far sì che noi
ragazzi personaggi di insideout tipo
gioia rabbia hanno anche loro delle
emozioni dentro la testa quelle emozioni
che stanno dentro la testa delle
emozioni hanno anche loro delle emozioni
è una cosa che non ho mai capito chi è
ciao zio di ucciderti e mi spiazza no se
un amico
cos'è in alaska
sorry ma non ci credo mai una torta ma
buttato giù no no no no dai
ma poi c'è dimmi dimmi veramente se puoi
spiegarmi ragazzi qualche 50 secondi
dove devo andare ai veloce veloce ma
anche venti secondi ma no non ci credo
praga 15 non ci posso che hanno perso o
sì o mio dio non ci credo ce l'ho fatta
qualche avan 10 secondi ce l'ho fatta la
propaggine a livelli proprio che sta il
ciao ciao ciao è tornato in 3d adesso
con ritornato in 3d che è quello ogni
emozione a una mossa speciale ed
esclusiva rabbia può camminare sulla
lana senza farsi male
ok all asp è che metterà così quindi
adesso se uso l'abbiano che figurava
bollente
no vabbè che roba fini quindi se cambia
personaggi possono dei poteri in più
fantastico erika rabbia è sempre stato
il mio preferito anche prima lo era p6
heart mother che crescere poteri già
disgusto può fare i salti più alti e se
dobbiamo cambiare un personaggio al
secondo cioè scusatemi disgusto cielo ma
va a pistoia che equilibrio che non è un
saluto discusso come avrei fatto c'è
veramente sto livello fa non lo potevo
fare senza i personaggi inside out cioè
senza averli tutti dico la brava
tristezza brava e adesso manca paura in
teoria giusto paura non me lo fanno
usare poverino corridore molto veloce
porta zio carri carè carè carè ogni
abbiamo mantova e velocissimo che cosa
il gran premio ma guarda è più veloce
del toro sa cosa ha paura è diventato in
assoluto il mio preferito dopo questa
infine ragazzi manca c'è gioia perfetto
ragazzi ci siamo manca eccola 4 certo
mancare sono più lei può planare su
grandi distanze
per questo lo sapevo ok a drastici
sta sparendo lorenzo stava mangiando di
dio mio dio mio dio guarda lo guardano
con si destreggia guarda la bellissima
paura è trovata una rampa di idea
ciao ragazzi ce l'ha chi ce l'ha per
cominciare non ci arriverò lo fosse si
andrebbe no no no no dài dài
mamma mia si può essere più stupito
ok ok perfetto
ci abbiamo fatto ragazzi incredibile è
stata na roba non so neanche come come
venuto male al cuore morire così è stata
una tragedia velo bonus velocità non
l'ho preso una volta sì la prima la
prima che era l'unica che dovrà andar
male invece monica andata bene beh
ragazzi bruno quale episodio se novice
poi loro tutto quanto comunque ragazzi
pero che video vi sia piaciuto e come
sento ragazzi se vivono piaciuto al
documento è un mi piace di facebook come
nel video trattenendo iscrizione ce
l'avresti di scrivere ci rivediamo nel
prossimo video ei ragazzi